knows
Hi, I'm a licensed dermatology provider from Cureology, answer a few questions, I'll look
at your skin and prescribe you a personalized cream.
Wow!
I wish we could watch the college football games we actually care about.
You can.
On ASPN with Slate, they have the kind of football that you love.
You can even choose and customize your channel lineup with Slate.
And you can watch it on your phone.
That's not so easy.
How do we get out of here?
Follow me.
I love this.
Yeah, that place was way too crowded.
Pre-pay and save with Season Pass and get the college football you care about.
Sling lets you do that.
Yeah.
Hi, hello, hello.
Hello! Oh, I'm just charging. I'll grab them the second I'm eating first.
Hi! Hello everyone! Hi!
I started a little bit early because my door-gash was here, so I ran downstairs.
And I met a dog. They were cool. It was a cute five-month-year-old labradoodle puppy.
Adorable, sweet. Tried to take my food, but that's okay.
Hi! Hi!
When we started yelling when I came back, I was like, why are you so cocky?
Yeah, I'm in the subject-getting mood because Fia is doing so well.
She's actually just put her in the litter box. Let me check with her.
You might hear her speak when I pick her up.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, you're snuddled.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's been acting super cute.
And I can't get over it how cute she'd be acting.
Ah, so I got some...
Boomi wants that shrimp. He probably did.
She's gonna come over here.
I might have gotten too much food because I got sushi and then hibachi, so I'm not gonna finish this.
But it'll be fine. Thanks, Boomi.
It'll be fine.
She just knocked over her stuff on my desk. How can I help you?
I don't even know.
But I'll have leftovers for tomorrow.
Here, maybe I should put on... Let's do an impromptu hand cam.
Oh my God.
This is heavy.
I also got tempura cheesecake because it just sounded good.
I need a sloucher.
Here's one.
Okay.
Game audio loud. I got you.
Yep, tempura cheesecake. I saw it. I never had that before. It sounded good.
So I'm like, you know what?
We're doing it.
We're treating ourselves today.
Let me grab my chamois.
Where's my chamois?
Oh my God. So many wires.
The really loud whistle of Mr. Chimes.
True. Sorry.
I don't have my headphones on so I couldn't tell how loud the audio levels were.
I apologize. I apologize.
Let me just untangle my...
Why did this get so twisted?
What have you guys been up to today? How's it been going?
What's new?
Did you eat today, Harlet?
Did you work hard today?
Turn on the freaking lights so I can see what I'm doing.
Let me move my keys.
Remind me my keys are beside my desk. I will forget.
A little small food hand cam. I still have the gum full of stuff out.
You took your lunch break early? Oh my gosh.
Oh my God. The temporary cheesecake though.
I think it was because somebody was making cheesecake. I really wanted cheesecake.
I'm definitely not eating all this. Holy crap. This is so much food.
What the hell?
I don't even know what this is. What is this? It's rice.
This is... Oh my God. I forgot. I got myself a sprite.
We're treating ourselves today with some soda. Normally I drink salto water.
And of course, Boomi's here to inspect.
Where did all this come from? Doordash?
I ordered two rolls in hibachi and I think my eyes were bigger than my stomach.
What did you get for Boomi? He has a roof over his head and he just ate cat food so he's fine.
Holy... guys.
I shouldn't have gotten the hibachi.
There's also... there's also like... why did they give me so much stuff?
What is this? Is this miso soup? And a shit ton of soy sauce? Oh my God.
That is a lot. We stan American portion sizes. Yes.
They gave me two sets of utensils which means they think that I'm two people.
Because they're like, wow, this is a lot of food. This has to be for two people.
I didn't know it would be this much.
Damn girl, you sure eat. I'm not finishing all this. I'll tell you that right now.
Yeah, my furthest person number two. I'm probably just gonna eat the sushi right now.
And I'll save this... the hibachi. Let's try it actually.
Let's do a little taste test, ladies and gentlemen.
Oh, that'd be looking delectable. Am I right?
A little bit of scrimp. They gave me three pieces of scrimp. What is up with that?
Little...
Mmm!
That looks... oh my God. That's delicious.
Alright, let's do a little... I got like, sauce everywhere. It's fine.
A little bit of... a little bit of steak. I get my medium.
Oh.
Lord, that is delicious.
Okay.
Veggies, because you know we gotta stay balanced.
This fork sucks.
Unofficial mukbang.
I just got sauce all over myself. It's fine. I just spilled it all over my desk.
You can see it there.
Okie dokie. I don't know where to put this. I gotta go put this on the counter.
I'm also not gonna eat all this, I don't think.
Although I am hungry, I haven't eaten all day.
It is 7 p.m. and your girl has not eaten.
I know for a fact that he's gonna try to steal this. Go away!
Damn, this bitch can eat. She th-
How do you think I got something for eyes, bro? I'm just kidding.
Looks like too much food for me to consume without being sick.
Welcome to here, member.
Why did you not eat earlier? You were tweeting 12 hours ago.
Because I get distracted?
I don't know what to tell you.
Now you guys can make fun of my chopstick- chopski-
And I'll skee skee skee my chopstick skills. I can't open this because of my nails.
Holy crap, this is huge. I thought it was gonna be like that and that.
Like just like small.
Hi, Shibi. It's me, Funtime Freddy. And welcome to Faith The Unholy Trinity.
Was this to constitute as a girl dinner? Nah, this is a man dinner.
Holy balls, you're brown. Nori! Hi, Nori. Yeah, I'm brown. Aren't you proud of me?
Look at that.
She got tempura shrimp and then Connie, you know?
Mm-hmm. Oh my god.
Mwah, chef's kiss. That's delicious.
And then I believe this is avocado, shrimp, and eel with a little bit of crunch.
Mwah. Mm-hmm.
It's really good.
I'm delicious, so.
Chat boxes froze. It always freezes.
I need to figure out how to get a different chat for it. I might just pull up the window and stick it in there.
Oh, there's Tobiko in it, too.
Yes, I wear the pants in the relationship.
What if I... Yeah, let's do a little... Let's pop out the chat.
I want to get a new chat widget.
Viewers are excited about a streamer's stash powers, delicious food delivery, and discuss their own eating habits.
Viewers are inspired to order takeout while others are trying to eat healthier. Thanks, AI.
Okay.
Let me... I think it was...
This one.
Oh my god. Look at you guys. Ah.
Look at you. You're so cute.
I have the chopsticks in my mouth like a walrus. You can't see it.
That works.
There we go. Looks like weird, but it's fine.
Do you want me to feed you?
I don't actually like putting soy sauce and stuff.
Well, I will. I occasionally will, but I usually don't.
So, open wide. Say ah. Ah. Ah, madam's going to feed you.
Remember, you're supposed to eat sushi in one bite.
Ready?
Here comes the plane.
How is it?
Mommy, baby's you on a date. ASMR role play.
Why is it spicy?
A shrimp. It's getting... I mean, a shrimp. The sprite.
Please, God. Delicious.
Don't really better cover your mouth when you burp. Don't burp in my face now.
Oh, this one's falling apart. Here, I'll get you a better one.
I'll get you a better one, baby girl.
You burped me in that.
All right. Open wide. I'm trying to get you a good piece.
This role is falling apart. I apologize.
All right. Open wide. Come on. It's falling out of my hand.
Go on now.
Are you ready? Here, I'm going to help you. Open your mouth.
Good. Good. Nice. Okay. Perfect.
How does that taste, my sweet little boy? Do you like the food?
All handsome?
What? Like my what?
Look at it on my hand.
Oh, my God.
You say my kuchi is fishy, Nori.
Here, you can eat this piece out of my hand.
Like the dog you are. Go on.
Go on. Do it.
And bark thank you afterwards.
Okay.
I'm so used to hand peeing.
I'm surprised Bumi's not like harassing me right now.
Oh, he's sleeping. What are you doing, big man?
Your butt looks huge from here.
Why is your mouth? You look so dumb right now.
He's looking back at me.
Can I take a picture?
Hold on. Bumi, don't move.
Bumi.
He looks so goofy, handsome boy.
He's literally, he looked at me with like cross eyes.
His mouth open and his badonkadonk just like out.
Yeah, his gya, he was sticking out his gya for the Rizzler.
That's all I'm going to say.
I think this one is the tail, so I'll just eat that with my hands.
Okay, it's your turn to feed me now.
Can you feed me?
Eat the wasabi.
No, it's like, it's not good wasabi, so it's not that crazy.
Like usually I can't handle wasabi.
Give her snort wasabi? Yeah.
All right, feed me.
Don't, don't hit my cheek with it.
Thank you.
Thank you. Oh my gosh.
The wishes. Thank you.
I got nonexistent hands.
Swabbing her hands. Where'd her hands go?
You guys spoil me.
Technically, you guys got me the sushi, so.
Because you pay for me to live.
So thank you. Thank you for dinner.
You're so sweet.
Oh, you're so sweet to me.
You're so good to me.
I don't deserve you.
How could I? How could I have someone like you?
All to myself.
My penis, I slam my penis in the car door.
Yeah, Nori's saying the quiet part out loud.
You didn't split the bill for dinner?
Oh, no, we split the bill.
I'm kind of like the one with the most tall people.
9, 9, 9, 9.
It's the autism, your honor.
What's the game about?
So you're a priest.
That's it.
You're a priest and you're fighting demons.
At least that's what I know.
And it's funny because I've seen this entire game play before.
I just don't remember any of it.
On my device, this is revolver.
No, it's a squirt gun.
Who's Chibi?
I'm Chibi.
Game is about mortis.
Did you make it for the pregame?
Yeah, we're on a dinner date right now.
I can't believe you're late to our dinner date.
How could you do that?
Should BB play it?
BB already played it.
I'm trying to avoid playing into BB too much because I think people will want me to become a nun.
And for reasons, because there's a nun in Gen 4.
John Faith defeats Gary on Holy Trinity.
Shot caller.
Yeah, there's no shot caller today.
Yeah, I don't want to get typecast precisely.
Eating a cheesesteak?
Good.
Nori, you're in.
I'm hiring you right now.
Like I have any power to do so.
Nori, I don't know.
I would laugh trying to listen to you record something for Patreon because I don't think you'll be able to take it seriously.
Nori for Gen 4, guys.
Nori for Gen 4.
You bought the shot caller for yourself?
You got a shot caller?
Ooh, yeah, it took forever to come in for me.
It took me like a month.
Wow, it's so big.
Wait, I have to do it in Nori's voice.
And what does it mean?
I don't record a lot.
Guys, the sushi is hitting.
I can't find where the other parts of the roll are.
I'm like craving eel.
You know what?
I should do one of those pregnancy audios like Strawny did for the entire week leading up to it.
I don't know.
I'm going to pretend that I have really bad cravings.
My friend's cat is named Gibi.
Oh, that's funny.
A pinky in the brain.
What?
Don't look at it.
Don't look.
I think it's everybody's favorite emo.
What's that one?
Here's a character named Sigma.
Oh my God.
A collab between Ambien Nori is doing brain rot memes.
Well, also like dorking your peanuts.
That'd be so funny.
Those cravings being Pee Pee McGee.
Two is some bumps and I'm going to be a dad.
Do a fancy stream right before the party.
Oh my God.
Why is that a good idea though?
It intimidates me because she's blonde.
Hello, she's ginger.
And second, I'm right here.
I'm also blonde.
And you want to eat her hair?
It looks like, like twirly candy.
You're black.
My nails are cute.
They're blue.
A lot of floof my rabbit ears.
No touchy.
They're sensitive.
Especially by tail.
My tail is also very sensitive.
People forget that I'm a bunny girl with a tail.
I'm out of sprite.
Can we touch the tail?
Only during buckshot roulette.
Looks at you.
Do you know that bunnies actually have very long tails?
Yes.
I think someone mentioned that.
And then I looked it up.
And I was like, what the hell?
Bunnies have super long tails.
They're just like, tuck it in.
My ears are not handlebars.
What is that?
What does the hedgehog stuff mean?
They're two to three inches.
They're tucking on the fluff.
Is your Bible bigger than a bunny tail?
Oh.
I like to pull.
Really?
That's interesting.
They tuck it in their bunny waistbands.
How many kids would this be now?
I have zero children besides my cats.
You want that?
Here.
Take.
Ah.
Good, good, good.
Chew.
Swallow.
Swallow it.
Good job.
Little pocket Bible.
Puppy in my pocket.
Be be in my pocket.
Yeah.
I decided because I'm like, I don't want to postpone stream so I can eat.
So let me just eat with you.
Make it a little, a little dinner date.
Good, good.
You guys are so well behaved today.
Thank you.
I need to burp.
That was solid.
You guys didn't hear that though.
I am eating nuts in a Gatorade.
Okay.
Female hyenas get the really shit end of the stick.
I'm doing okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
Don't starve.
Don't starve like I did.
You got it all over my shirt.
This is messy and I just vacuumed today.
And when I say I just vacuumed, I mean I turned on Zumba and he zoomed around.
Did I get down my shirt?
Oh my God.
It did.
Are you kidding me, bro?
What is that?
I got it all over me.
I got a Hoover my own boobs.
I can't.
Delicious.
It's in my, it's in the, the bitty crack.
I can't get this.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I'm going to have to vacuum again.
Shoeshee flavor.
All right.
Well, I'm happy I put this napkin down.
This is a good call on my, on my.
No, I just show it here when she just moves everybody out the way.
Boop sweat.
New fantasy unlocked.
Eating food off me.
That'd be a good script actually.
And just like one thing leads to another and then.
She be was mine first.
She's not wrong.
I've set up a four nor is the one when I was super small.
It gave me a chance and she lifted me to greater heights.
There's Toby go all over my desk.
Oh, no.
We're all out of dishes and I have all this sushi to serve.
What am I going to do with all these plates of sushi?
You guys get it for an adult.
You guys ate all this.
I'm literally a little kid, John.
What does she watch out?
Oh, that's cool news for you.
Someone I talked to in discord randomly sent me your channel saying he loved your stuff.
He was surprised when I told him I was already here.
That's awesome.
That's so amazing.
I'm so glad people like, um, I, I, that's like that.
That's like, I think the second time someone said that to me, like they were like, Oh, someone sent me you, but I already was watching you.
And I was like, what?
That's so funny.
Me and them doing something right.
Fire, fire, fire.
Couldn't find the emoji.
Look at the AI.
Hold on.
What the AI saying, what the dog doing?
I don't know if it's going to work because I popped out chat.
No, he's protective.
She beat and does not want to share.
That's funny.
That is indeed a good, a good summary.
I agree with that summary.
Okay, last piece.
It's for you.
You can have it because you've been so good.
You can have the last piece here.
There you go.
You like it?
Yeah.
Good.
Fan girl fan.
He's strict.
Do you even know the name of my band?
They all love me like they want to hold hands.
All because I'm she be cotton bum.
Girl failure.
Dom of gen one.
Be a lure.
Oh my God.
Stacey.
It's Eminem.
I never had the lyrics go.
Please won't you please let me suck your rocks.
I love the crunchy bit.
That would be so funny.
No, there's no more spline.
Okay, cool.
Was it?
I didn't listen to his latest album.
Vangirl.
All right.
I want to take a bite of this temporary cheesecake.
Let's see if I can eat it.
I still have freakin' stuff in my boot.
Let me put this in the fridge.
This is a lot of food.
I mean, it's time to crack a cold one for the boys.
Oi, oi, oi.
Omelander stormy sun.
We recycle in this household.
Are you recycling?
You better be recycling, harem.
You better be separating your plastic and your glass and your cardboard.
These chicks don't even know the name of my band.
Who's Eminem?
That's a good joke, Nori.
You freaking...
Oh my God, Nori.
I'm going to kill you in Minecraft.
Ladies and gentlemen, sheltered woman right here.
Sheltered baby.
All right, guys.
Let's see.
I'm recycling.
I'm American.
I'm also American.
Ooh.
I hate maraschino cherries, but ooh.
Architect Rose eating good tonight.
It goes all to my thighs and my booba.
Ooh.
What the hell?
Do I have to cut this?
I need a knife.
I don't like cherries.
I don't like maraschino.
I can't pronounce it.
You know what I'm talking about.
Maraschino?
Machinima?
I don't like machinima.
Machinima cherries are not my favorite.
Oh, good.
I hope it goes well, Charlie.
Thank you for the member update.
All right.
Let's try it.
Cross section.
Cross section doko.
Oh my God.
Holy crap.
That is one of the best things I've ever tasted.
You want to bite?
I'll let you bite.
Hold on.
Let me cut you off a little bite, sweetheart.
It's very good.
I think you'll like it.
The graham cracker is exceptional with the tempura.
This is very hard to cut in this little bowl.
Hello?
Can I cut this off?
I'm struggling with this piece.
Okay.
Here comes the plane.
Here he comes.
There he is.
There you go.
You didn't have to take the fork with you, too.
What do you think?
I think it's pretty delicious.
I think it's pretty delicious, guys.
Get those cherries out.
I'll eat them.
I just don't want to eat them right now.
This is really good.
I needed something sweet.
I don't have anything sweet.
Cheesecake is delicious.
I remember I used to hate cheesecake.
I don't know what was wrong with me.
No, cheesecake doesn't make my tummy hurt.
Delicious shows a certain streamer website.
I should have had milk with this.
You can get your daily dose of microplastic somewhere else,
you goofball.
Did you say praise the Lord before eating?
I don't know, did I?
I'm a pagan.
That doesn't make any sense.
How could I?
Although I say praise a lot, you know, as one does.
Yeah, I never liked cheesecake.
Did you eat cheesecake with your sister?
Okay, there's still like little fish eggs in my mouth,
so I just popped one and it was kind of weird.
Can I eat the lid?
Of course.
Here you go.
Here's a lid.
Oh, oh, you really took that.
All right.
Okay.
Got to get the palate cleanse.
I like how you spoke palate as in like a wood palate.
I need to burp.
More of a cake girlie or a pie girlie?
I'm more of a pie girlie.
I love me some apple pie.
I make really good apple pie.
And I make really good apple crisp.
Hold on, I got a burp for you.
Solid.
Tell me that wasn't solid, bro.
Tell me.
Eight out of ten.
All right.
Hold on.
I'll give you a better one.
I need tens across the board.
Week?
Hold on, hold on.
What about that?
I got a smell across the screen.
Six out of ten.
Seven.
I was like, I think the only time I got a ten out of ten was when I did the thing during
Wolf Quest when I was drinking that Korean soda.
And I just burped for like a minute.
That's made into a short, by the way.
It'll be up in a couple of days.
I can't wait for people to call me a fat lard because I eat food on stream.
I don't care.
I am hungry.
I haven't eaten all day.
This is a big bite.
I prefer apple pie.
I'm not a huge pumpkin pie fan.
Is Johnny making a cake short?
I don't know.
I think she's highlighting that.
This is a member stream, so I have to figure it out.
But I know that would probably go freaking viral.
Johnny was like, what did you do on stream?
Can you grab me?
Can you give me download the mod for me?
Wait, I can just go into your account and do it myself?
Thank you.
That's literally what she said.
Yes.
I prefer crust.
Although cheesecake, I like the crust, like the graham cracker crust.
Does it say so cake?
Yeah, you're right.
It was just a say so big cake baking stream.
This was slapped with ice cream.
You never had cheesecake nori?
I feel like you wouldn't like it just knowing you.
Yes.
I like really, really crispy apple crisp with really good crumble and an ice cream.
Probably looks like pumpkin chocolate.
This isn't really what cheesecake looks like.
Lemon rink.
I don't really like lemon things.
The only lemon thing I've eaten that I actually liked was my mom's lemon squares.
My mom is a really good baker.
I can't cut this.
It's just a mess now.
Whatever.
That's as good as it's going to get.
This looks fucking disgusting.
There we go.
Tres leches.
Oh, don't even get me started on tres leches.
I fucking love tres leches.
Cake.
Oh my God.
Mmm.
Mmm hmm.
Say it right.
You know I'm not Spanish.
How am I going to say it right?
Tres leches.
It's funny.
Some lady was the woman with the dog that I talked about at the beginning of the stream.
She was talking to me in Spanish and I'm just like, I don't know what you're saying.
Oh my God.
That's so funny though.
Dios mío.
I can't.
Free milks.
One milk, two milk, three milk.
Favorite ice cream.
I like Oreo cookie ice cream alone by itself.
However, I'm a huge cold stone fan.
So I like birthday cake remix is my favorite flavor.
Don't laugh at me.
What are you guys?
Don't look at me like that.
I love cold stone.
There's not one any near me though.
There's only my near my grandparents because they're in the south for some.
I don't know why there's like none up here, but it's, I don't know.
Maybe because it's New England.
They're just like, it's cold enough.
Cotton candy with Reese's peanut butter.
That sounds disgusting.
I don't like cotton candy.
It's too sweet because it's literally, you know, sugar.
Okay.
Now I'm full.
Never had stewards.
Cold stone, my beloved.
They're slowly coming up here.
Maybe.
I hate pistachio ice cream here.
Disgusting.
And mint chocolate chip.
What is wrong with people who like green ice cream for real?
I need to take out the trash.
I'm mean.
Like mint chip.
Mint chocolate chip tastes disgusting.
Come for me.
Do it.
Come at me, bro.
Come at me.
Hold on.
I'll show you.
I was going to be like, come at me, bro.
Come at me, bro.
Do it.
Fight me.
Fight me right now.
Do it.
I'm grabbing my watch.
Hey, I'm about to scorn me with you.
Take the baby.
Baby has been taken.
We turn off the light so it's not in your face.
This bed is too big.
Fiat on the cat cam.
Sorry, Fiat.
Let me spin you so people can see your face.
Fiat on the cat cam.
Why Fiat reaction?
She's just a baby.
The picture, yeah.
Fiat was in our mouth and she was playing with me.
Here we go.
Tee-fee.
Oh.
Yeah, let's get Fiat.
Let's get Fiat a little treat.
Let's get all the kitties a little treat.
So they love, they love this.
They love greenies.
Oh, boomy.
You want some?
Reina, you want some?
Reina, can you take these?
Can you sit?
Can you sit, Reina?
Sit.
Reina, sit.
Good girl.
Well, me doesn't do any tricks because he's useless.
Here you go, Reina.
Oh, lady.
I don't want to cast a spell on you.
You want it?
You want a treat?
Oh.
Girl, you lost it.
She's been really good at chewing too.
I'm really happy.
I fed her some dry food today because she can chew again.
Before it was she just didn't have the jaw strength to chew.
But now she does so she can crunch stuff you want another one. Oh, yes, you do
Yes, you do mom was
I'll give you one more. Oh, I just dropped it
Here the cats are like wait, where's the rest of the tree?
Yeah
Good girl
Yeah, she munchin she be munchin now I was trying to give her her liquid food after I gave her some cable, but she was
She was already full from the cable. I was really happy
And I gave her some liquid food
Because she still needs obviously like water
If you're ever feeding an animal
And they can't like drink make sure you thicken it with food
Because then it'll help their minds differentiate and they won't choke on it as easily
I still have stuff
Oh
Okay, right now you can't hop in that back to what you know what you're gonna play in the background you can play in the bag
There you go
Oh
My god, she's not gonna be on the cam for long. I'm just gonna I just want to show you guys her how cute she is
how precious
Got their tail, you know, we tuck that back in
She's just a little nugget. Yeah, just a little nugget
Oh
She's very soft. She's a very soft kitty
Feel my death by companion
I just got chick flayed livered and there is no chicken just a bag full of fries and one cookie
Oh
Stash I am so sorry
Raina just walked away with the bag. Um
She just hissed at boomi because boomi kind of tried to get the bag. Oh my god, that sucks bro
That's funny as heck at the same time
Okay, I have to open a pulsoid app
Come on apple watch I need to get a new apple watch band
Do do do because this one I have a braided I have a braided loop but they like stretch pretty easily
Do
And I don't like the other straps
I opened it. How do I
How do I freaking I forgot to use an apple watch
Please hold
Is it not working please please
Have you tweeted that you're live? No, I'll tweet that I'm live
Is it working
I can't tell if it's working
My dad is texting me
He sent me the
trailer for thunderbolts and I'm like this is stupid
I'm not watching this
He's just like yeah, it sucks and I'm like word
Actually, no, I didn't tell if he could tell if he thought it was after not
Oh
Come on. Oh, there it is. Okay. There we go
Do do do
There we go. Let me stick this on my head
We love to see it
I'm at I don't know why I'm at 99. Maybe because I'm just so excited to see fia into you guys
Yeah, that ball in wolverine though was incredible. I like was like, yes, this is what I wanted
Okay, I'm gonna turn off the camera for now just because I know I'm gonna knock it over and just like I don't want it to fall
on fia
But uh say bye
Say goodbye. Say. Goodbye
Say bye. Oh, you gotta be on
Yeah, she'll still be on my desk, but I'm just gonna turn off the camera
Okay
You showed dad the gunpla. Oh, I haven't showed my dad the gunpla
I forgot to send him a picture because I think that's the one I fell asleep
Because that's when he was texting me
I should show up with it in person
I like how it just froze with that after I unplugged it
She's she's grooming herself after that delicious meal
Those delicious treats. I should have fed her a little fishy for you guys. Maybe I'll do that later
I'll feed her a little fishy. I have um
I have minnows
Like a freeze-dried minnows that I give the cats is a little like meal topper because I spoil my babies and um
Yeah, hold on. Let me fix my
I
Hope that's not it
There we go. I'm gonna turn them physics back on. There we go. Now I can move around a lot faster and
I'll make this I'm like, I'm so fast. You can't do anything about it. All right
So we're gonna play some faith
We got the monitor going
If yes is by
What's this? Oh, it's my drink
Good girl. Now you can just chill with me
Hold on. Let's check out my tomagachi
Oh
My god, there's poop everywhere
I checked on it this morning, but you know, I have a life so I can't just be on the tomagachi all day
I don't think tomagachi's die die anymore
It just took a selfie with poop in the background and uploaded it
And uh and the because they take medicine every time. I don't know. Maybe if I left it for like days, maybe you would die
I can't let pekora die
I'm gonna feed her lobster sub
The child is our life now. Okay, then do something about it
I don't know if on reward. I send you this tomagachi uni so you can take care of our child
And then you can just take care of our child perpetually because I don't know how I would get it back
Dies in transit no
Oh
No, yeah, no I got I just have the wigs because I yeah the pre you could the presale sold out
Oh, she's she's depressing. Hold on. Have some cereal
Wait, what what snacks did I buy?
Have some rain candy. I don't know what the hell that is. Oh, she really likes it though
She really likes rain candy
Yeah, you tell him boomi
Eat the summer tart
Ooh, she likes the summer tart as well
Paddling custody with money live on stream
Boomi, what are you doing?
You just you just yelling at no one in particular
Come on, let me put my headphones on because I don't know if you guys did uh dough knows or anything
You can support me by clicking on the link in the description below
Or super chatting however
YouTube takes more of a cut
Than streamlamps
So make the right choice
I just realized is that link to that? No, it's not. Okay, sorry
I was like, um messing with my mixer, so I didn't know if it was turning down my mic volume
Or else you're gonna get caught
But
Why is this music so cheerful?
Ladies and gentlemen
Wait
We caught on this from a day ago. Why didn't I see this for boomi's lawyer boomi's lawyer has it out for me? I swear
Oh
Oh my goodness, I've been like sniffly with allergies all day. Oh my god
Thank you. Thank you. I'm like trying to fix the chat. Oh, that's weird. Why is it like that?
Thank you. Thank you all
Oh my god, boomi, boomi just slammed into the miter cycling
Let me go fix that
I need to take off my shorts
Recycle in this household, where did you go?
I don't know where you went
There you are. What are you up to mister?
You looking suspicious
I'm really just wearing
a hoodie a t-shirt
Hitties and crocs right now because that's how I roll. That's how I roll in this household
Okay
Sorry, hold on. Let me check on this tomagotchi. What's your food at?
Okay, I need to feed it some more
Sorry, I have like zoomer. Oh cherry pie. You can eat that if you put cherry pie
Zoomer attention span
I still have to get another controller
All right, let me tweet that I'm live
Sounds like this I should walk down to this for our our wedding. This should be our song that I did I walk down to
I
Boomi, can you stop throwing yourself all over the place? Thank you
Did you wear a collar always?
My heart beats so my heart rate's so high because uh, I just ate so much food and my body's trying to process it
I also need to take off my bra
That wasn't a burp that was just me going
Walking the we're wearing dresses
Just chapter two just chapter two. I want to do just like parts
Boomi, why do you look so cracked out bro? What's up with that?
What are you good? Are you fighting your demons?
Huh he's like tweaking out on the cat tree right now
So
Wait, what is what?
Everything's in latin maybe a cat dip. I don't know how
No, he's not seeing any spirits. I'll tell you that much. She's just he's just goofy
Notes, okay, is a slender man do I have to collect different notes?
Turbo
There's a prologue
Notes are for lower
It's sound good it sound cool
I do like overalls
Wake up in the morning feeling like peed city grab my glasses. I'm out the door. I'm gonna hit this city
Father Garcia, wait, no, I gave him like a Nicholas Kate Nicholas Nicholas cage voice now. I'm Sean Connery
Father Garcia, you are here. No, I forget how I did the voice
Father Garcia, you are here boy instructed to release Michael Davies from your custody and return him to his home immediately
Mr. Oh, I know this is it
This is a different dude
It doesn't matter mr. And mrs. Davies. I've already been in contact by her office
A representative of the church was currently in route to their home to discuss compensation return for their discretion
You will meet our representative there company back
Company him back to Rome. I struggle reading stuff
From chapter. Yes, I yeah, I know no, I know him
But I'm just assuming he reads everything out loud so I could just read everything the same voice
Oh another day another dollar
Hmm am I in jail? Why is like the toilet right there?
Be gone spirits. Can I grab my bible?
No, I can't grab that
All right, can I sprint? No
He pissed in there. What do you yeah?
Which reminds me I should probably
How do I get out of here? Oh, is this the door? That's a closet
Guys am I stupid? Oh wait, is it over here?
Yeah
Oh nice one day
He looks really happy
Two weeks. Okay, doesn't look too good
Three months. Oh, wow. He looks really handsome in that photo. I do say
Uh, let me check downstairs real quick. I don't know. I have a I have a car battery over there the antenna, but that's fine
Are you ready for your your session sexy boy? Welcome to my dungeon
You've been tied to the bed now. I get to have my way with you
To make you bitter at first
Oh
They demode they call me pendejo what the hell
What
I feel like I wasn't supposed to do that now
Oh everything's still around I just can't see
All right
Yeah, I just I just hold you guys down and I just
And I just hold a cross in front of you
What are you doing? Who did you just eat?
Oh
The food is supposed to stay in your mouth, sweetie
I have the body of a pig
I got exercise your demons
What the heck
Why did I just like hello my baby? Hello my honey out the freaking frame
Hello my rock time, girl
Have you forgotten already the notes people leave behind oh, I don't really care. That's just yeah
la la la
Jumping up and down holding all around
Uh that tree looks funny. Hey, I don't think tree is supposed to look like this
What happened to you
The current investigation being conducted at the gallup cemetery by the state of connect
Connecticut
Historical society has been postponed until further notice in an interim
We asked the public to avoid cemetery grounds the surrounding woods any wildlife and any unidentified persons roaming in the area
Thank you for your patience
Ah, my god
Insert creative message here. Oh, thank you. See you now. Thank you for um being a member for a month
You
Something tells me I should be
Ha ha I found you
I just okay wait hold on
I
He looked like a lost friend
Don't worry harem I'll hold your hand
You thought that was in game
Whispers in your ear
All right
What the heck what door makes that noise
All right, let's go around the trees then and come down here
Wait, was that maybe I'm supposed to go up still? Maybe I'm supposed to go up
I feel like something tells me I'm supposed to keep going up past the graves
I think I got too ahead of myself
Let's do that again. Sorry
Wish I could dilly dally a little bit faster. That'd be great
Oh
Wait, hold on I got you hold on
Disciple
Fairly is that working?
I don't think so. Hold on
Here it is. Here it is. That's a pitch
Ha ha where's the deep pitch
Dearest disciple why does it sound like that? What's up with the
It's supposed to just make my voice deeper and isn't doing that. Hello. What the hell? I just sound like a dude
Now I sound like an anime character. Wait, what the hell? That's supposed to sound like that
Dearest disciple
Everyone who says lucifer use lucifer as an inheritance kingdom
He must first conjure his demon. He must then serve his demon. He must then walk among the children of men as his demon
Thus shall you first see the blessing of the unspeakable
As a family tongue whenever you are in need of rest
I don't know why it sounds like hard tune is on ha la la. Oh lucifer lucifer
Jason
Oh, no, it's scary
Now we got the what hold on I need to fix that
La la la la
La la la la la la la. What's this?
Because it's supposed to make it sound like a pitch wide
How about now why
Why does it sound like that? Why hello? Why does oh there we go. That's what I wanted
There we go. No, I have the demonic voice now. Now I sound scary
Now
You're not safe from me
Ah
Barry the platypus, I'm the true demon
Can I can I get out of here, please? Oh
Ha ha ha ha ha
Oh wait, I can be british she be again. Hello. Hello everyone. It's me british she be
I'm sorry. This is gonna just turn into me not playing the game in just messing with the go axel
Oh, it's a save interesting. Okay. Let me see if I can
Do some stuff
A
Platypus demon Barry the platypus demon
Yep, all right
Hello, how's it going? What's going on? Oh, you don't you don't look so good there. Um
All right, what about you? Okay, cool. I like this. This is not I don't like that
Oh
I have a key okay, and then their spirits
Why do they look half eaten that they look so weird
Stream where she be doesn't play the game. You mean every strip mods
Bonk his head at once. Oh my god. That's so rude
All right, let's go over here first. Yeah
Yeah
The fact that I can't hold up a crucifix at the same time as walking is crazy
Just like how I can't walk and drink at the same time. I just am mentally incapable of doing that
I don't think I'm gonna choke
God's sees him my mods are asleep. It's fine. Well, it's not but you know what I mean
Why am I stuck? Why can't I walk this aside? Okay?
What why are there clouds this is so big
Is this supposed to be fog I just got really dizzy all of a sudden oh gosh
Oh
joy
Um bros I think I'm stuck
I wish there was a note that I could have if I hold it
I
Just be a pattern
How should there be a I don't maybe I shouldn't have gone over here yet because I don't have anything to help me with this
Can I just kms kiss my sister
Amy, where are you?
Go back to previous area
I would love to oh what all right
I was worried that I would just be trapped there
Hello fuck
I can't see you
Oh
Mortis
More kiss wait did I already have the key?
Spooky
Um
I watched like the behind the scenes of the developer doing the rotoscoping for this and it was actually really cool
it just
It just makes it like have this uncanny valley. That's like super creepy
Because it's like human movements, but in an unusual, you know like medium in format
Oh
Excuse me
More kiss more kiss more like more kiss
If literally okay, I wish it would save after I grabbed this key
It's not a boss though. It's just a guy. How am I supposed to kill it?
Maybe I'll go another place for now. It's just let's just let's just explore
So I know that dude's down there that'll probably get one of those spirits
Uh
All right, that's too bad. It's crazy. I can just walk around it
Dee dee dee dee dee it looks like I have a giant shlong between my legs
When I walk straight and I just like
It is dangling, you know
Time to start a new life in the woods. Just kidding
Wait, but don't I have a key?
I swear I have a key though
This dangles. Yeah, now I bet you can't unsee it because I said that
Oh, is this the key to it
No
Oh, the other you has it. Oh joy
Time to go fight my other you
My other me I should say
It is with great sadness, just a sterling community announces the passing of Cindy martin
Parents their lives tragically came to an end on September 21st due to an accident in their home
Bob was a training advisor for the united states navy and Cindy was a cba
And more recently a stay-at-home mother. They were married march 12 1969 in fallen town
But not particularly religious. They taught their children to be kind generous and involved in the community
A public closed casket memorial will be held tilling after you go home and attending on thursday
Your real service for real services will proceed shortly thereafter
Bob and Cindy are survived by their daughter Amy and my boys nate and jason
Like a kid narrating I know I want to add some layer of creepy to it, you know
I
Honestly because of this game, I'm not surprised more like similar games haven't come out of people trying to copy the style
Because it's very cool and unique
Bye-bye
What that
Guys I'm not good at puzzles
Wait, I spammed a little and something happened
Oh wait
I need to do a cross
Can I do it again?
It was how I was walking face self
I'm facing self
Right magnum dong
Oh
I've cooked poorly, but you know it's still a manageable meal
Back off I'm not about it
I
Be gone tree wonder what my cross is white
A statue moved
Down there
Did it I didn't even notice
Oh
Get your thing along you look like a frog
What
Oh
Mortis okay, this one should be easier
It's losing its luster
Oh it did move what the hell
What are you doing stop it get some help
You
All right, what land you it looks doesn't it look like a frog with an umbilical cord am I wrong?
Okay
All right
Looks like crazy frog
Ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding bam bam bam ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding dong
Ah
Go go go go go go go go go go go go go
Crazy frog was packing he what are you talking about?
I forget I have to like look at them. I can't just do it
Oh
Okay, so I kind of got a backup more ever again. I have to like look at them. I just can't be holding it up
Hello
Kermit got into some weird stuff
Kermi no
I'm just like I could I can beat the dancing lion in five tries, but faith can't do it guys can't do it
I'm
Get your just give it a pee pee away from me
Oh, wow, this is so annoying. Should I be out of the way?
Okay
You're not on gamer subs right now faith does have hands
It's mostly because I just still don't understand the mechanics. I need to shmove
I like the way you move
Me beep beep. I like the way you shmove
I
Gyrates in the trees
All right, let's just go up here. Oh
I missed
Frick it's also I it's hard for me to tell where I am in space because it's pixels
I
Can you kite them cross then move maybe
Yeah, I yeah, usually they just yeah, they have they have like a a move set
Why can't I just walk across just hop the fence be a real man
Hop the fence with your magnum schlong. No, probably we get stuck like that one, uh, olympics
Guy that hit his boba to boopy on the high bar
I need to sit up with my chair my chair is like all the way back
Oh, that's better. Okay now i'm locked in
I wish you could skip the cutscenes after a little bit
Oh
Make some distance
I'm stuck
Wait he just swooped up guys, uh
This is gonna be a long chapter two kermit
Yeah, I was a very swoopy wave it was swoopier than the other wave
I guess maybe the wave gets bigger
I will handle
So yeah, he gets he comes out of straight then he comes at us in a little wave
And he comes at us in a little thing and he comes at us in a bigger wave
Yeah, I get fucked
All right, I don't know why that was so difficult for me to do
Nobody was thrilled when I got pregnant not even a little happy
And my doctor seemed to be judging me
Every time I'd leave the doctor's office. I'd see this strange woman across the street
All she do is stare at me and smile
No words just a big warm smile
Somehow it made those visits a little more bearable
After I lost the baby I saw her again across the street from the doctors
Her smile was as big as ever
But somehow not as warm and friendly as I remember
Yesterday I was walking was shocked to see the woman standing in the middle of a path
Now she was pregnant. She beckoned towards me
I followed her off the path into the woods
That's what I meant Gary
First try gg easy
I killed that woman's baby. No, I did I did no such thing
Oh, I can't do that. So let's just go fight this dude. Can I save?
Hey B, aha nifty
La-la-la-la-la-la-la. Oh
Now I know it's right up left up
Let's fight this guy first though
Okay, MC screaming baby.
This and grandpa was one of the hardest things I've ever experienced.
We were really close.
I cried about it for weeks.
Then my stepmom introduced me to some of her friends.
They asked me,
Would you like to see your grandfather again?
I missed him so much.
I was willing to try anything.
That night my stepmom drove me to one of her friend's house.
They took me down to the basement.
I saw my grandfather in there.
Only, it wasn't actually him.
When I tried to run, they closed the basement door and locked me in.
I can't remember much else from that night.
My stepmom's friends are always coming by the house now.
They tell me I have a debt to pay.
They say they have work for me to do.
It's again a narrator.
Hype. Hype for making streams.
Oh, their heads are gone.
That's lovely.
Right, up, left, up.
Right.
Up.
I was right, they didn't do it on accident.
Left.
I bet people have accidentally brute-forced this without meeting two.
Up.
Cool.
I've been freed.
No overbearing father turned violent alcoholic.
No more hiding my bruises and cuts.
No more pills and needles.
No more getting laughed at and kicked around.
They'll never laugh at me again.
By day, my body withers away.
But by night, my mind explores forbidden worlds of power and knowledge,
guided by beings of pure darkness.
I have been trusted with the secret knowledge of the demon seal.
I have learned the correct conjuring sign,
drawing the inverted star along the rocks arranged in five.
First at the top left point, then down.
I'll lure them into woods.
Then I will show them my power.
Did you know if you do the five-pointed star in reverse, it is banishment?
And it's actually protective?
The pentagram is not inherently a demonic thing.
Alrighty.
I feel like I'm missing something.
La la la la.
Hey, what's up?
Can I have it?
Oh.
Ow?
Thanks.
Now I'm just bleeding from my eye.
I'm bleeding from my magnum dong.
Oh, I thought it was going to have me make a five-pointed star.
Yeah, the inverted cross is also, yeah.
The magnum dong.
At least I'm not bleeding.
I wonder if I, like, actually got stabbed in the eye.
I feel like I should be.
Yup.
There's all these X marks of spots around.
It killed me?
Uh, that tree just made like a leaf.
And leafed.
That's all I'm going to say.
Today's my birthday.
A very happy, open Pokemon card.
What?
You pulled a rare $400 shiny Charizard?
Happy birthday and congrats.
Oh my God, that's awesome.
Alright, which freaking tree is this?
Where are you?
Show yourself.
Do it.
No?
Alright.
It's a great birthday gift.
Oh, where's purple guy going?
I can't, sometimes I just can't walk past things.
Why is this house so big?
Why can't I walk past the roof?
What?
I don't like cornfields like that.
Oh.
Nifty.
I had to come back.
I had to walk through the corn one last time.
I wasn't sure what I would find.
The dogs.
The children.
Nothing I'd talk about.
It had been five years.
I couldn't even find the little graves anymore.
I just walked in the field until I found that stupid grinning scarecrow.
As I listened to the night wind blowing through the crops, it was like the scarecrow was mocking me.
I turned around to go back and that's when I heard it behind me.
Well, it was more like I felt it.
That scared me in the noise of the background.
I didn't dare turn around.
It just stood there.
Me.
The scarecrow.
And the doomed child.
Finally, I mustered up a tiny bit of courage and turned the look.
It immediately fled in the opposite direction, crashing through the rows of corn.
I ran to the little I saw that drained the blood from my face and made my skin crawl.
I say it because whatever it was looking at it didn't have a face.
Just a bloody gaping hole.
Alright.
Hello, child.
Any child in this corn?
Children of the corn? Anyone?
Will I help you?
I'm trying.
Hey, look at this guy again.
Will you help me?
The way we stack in y'all ended up like children of the corn.
Interesting.
Okay, I think I just go back to the house.
It's William Sheepie.
Purple guy, William Afton.
It's William Cottonbomb.
Oh, okay.
Gotcha, gotcha.
Actually, hold on.
Before I go into the house, I just kind of want to look around.
Can I go over here?
Oh, cursed rock.
What about on this side?
Please, for the love of God, can I just run?
I'm moving like molasses.
More rocks?
Don't mind if I do.
Let me take a bite of these delicious rocks.
Let me take a seat on these delicious rock.
Oh, that makes sense.
Will you help me?
Confess license.
I'm a whore, your honor.
All right.
Day one of our paranormal investigation to the Old Snake Meadow Hill Church.
We've got three cameras, a box of tapes, and just enough beer and beef jerky to last us a week.
It's a lot of beef jerky on our way, and we asked some of the locals of the church.
It was mostly the stories we'd heard before.
Evil spirits dragging children to the color field and secret tunnels under the chapel.
But there was this spindly lady game that we hadn't heard yet.
Apparently, it has to do with summoning the spirit of a woman who used to take care of the orphans back in the 50s.
There was even an old rhyme they told us.
Walk the church from room to room, and maybe he will see her.
She will move when you do, but never try to trick her.
Awesome.
We're going to try the game tonight as soon as we get settled in.
Interesting, but never try to trick her.
I'm wondering if these represent the rooms?
Confessed to be be last week.
Yeah, because now, see, this is the candles representing of what room I'm in.
I'm assuming she's in the last room.
At least that's what I think.
Sick purple skull, bro.
There's a lot of crosses in here.
Beautiful confessional.
Honestly, the pixel art is so good in this game.
I know it's super simple, but it's not at the same time.
All right, I guess I'll go in here.
Pray for me, father, for I have sinned.
You have sinned, you have sinned, you have sinned, you have sinned.
I tried to save a girl from evil.
But my dear soldier gave me.
I turned my mechanism in history.
And broke my house to God.
Oh man.
A year later, the girl reached out to me again.
She reached out.
Oh wait, that was when I went back.
I am sorry for me that my best sins.
Now his sin will kill you life in it.
Bring the child to me before we see them together.
Why would I just go?
He will kill you the peace now, see this.
He vicks to know it for you good.
For his mercy and yours forever.
Why would I want to listen to the random demon in the confessional?
Oh, see now I've moved to the next room.
All right, and she must be in two rooms over.
I love like one of my favorite sculptures is our mother of sorrows.
I can't remember.
Just a really gorgeous, beautiful statue of Mother Mary.
Or at least to some other saint, female saint.
All right, can I?
No.
Hi, Tomah!
Yeah, this is where mortis is from.
Okay.
So then if I go, there must be a way for me to go into the center middle room.
I just don't know how.
Is that to do with her?
Oh.
We still have a fight.
We still have a fight our way into the basement.
But we found something just as cool.
A secret passage in the Old Confession, both leading to this hallway.
Henry's going to town to fire a crowbar.
We'll see if we can't get these boards off some of these doors.
That's not even the best part.
We caught an EVP.
Can't hear it on tape very well, but to us it's a kind of Saturday night laughing.
Thank God we brought the nice mic.
We'll review it on the sound gear once we get back into town.
I wonder why it's bloody.
There must be a crowbar somewhere then.
Hmm.
Where's night two?
Night two.
Alright, so I'm in the center, so I guess maybe I can go straight up.
She is in the top room.
Okay, no, she's in the, she moves again.
Nice voice acting, thank you.
I saw something move when I walked in there.
Let's see if I can make it happen again.
Oh, where is she?
The flames out.
I mean she's in the room with me, isn't she?
I gotta go, I gotta go, I gotta go, I gotta go.
Alright.
Wait, where am I?
I can't tell which one I am.
Oh, here's night two.
Should flash everything?
Yeah, I should.
We're gonna be rich.
We've caught the supernatural stuff on camera before, sure.
Doors opening on their own, things falling off the shelves, nothing like this.
Tonight we'll be trying this spindly lady game again.
One of the candles on the floor lit up by itself as soon as Lars walked into the room.
No, it was nuts and we got it all on film.
We're gonna make a fortune selling this to Stevie's stations.
Alright.
Yeah, she's in the top room.
Okay, so I was right.
So that does represent her moving around.
Aren't I wicked smart?
Let me see.
Very beautiful mosaics.
Cool.
Oh, interesting.
Fascinating, fascinating.
I can't tell if it's a broken candle on the ground.
Oh no, she's in the same room.
Gotta go, gotta go, gotta go, gotta go, gotta go, gotta go, gotta go, gotta go.
Okay, this is another part of the chapel.
Watch the candles.
Yeah, no duh, I've been watching the candles.
Okay, I think I need to spam more stuff.
I'm surprised I haven't found the crowbar yet.
It's a really pretty cross.
Alright, she is far away.
Well, she's getting closer to me.
Why is there?
It seems like something's under this rug because it keeps twitching.
I need you to move.
Why does it do that?
Okay, that's the basement.
There's stairs, that's what it is.
Where do I get down there?
Okay, she's behind me.
It's giving me a hint.
Huh, that when I walk into a room something opens.
Okay, we switch places.
I'm gonna go, hold on actually.
I didn't check these out yet.
This is cool, this is spooky, I'm feeling spooked.
Maybe through the confession book?
Yeah, I'm thinking about going through the confessional again.
Cause there's a little hallway on the other side.
Is there like another one?
Okay, well.
Cause this one's covered in blood.
I'm just wondering why that is.
Cause there's gotta be a crowbar somewhere.
So she's in the center room.
Cat food dispenser, my beloved.
Maybe I'm supposed to have her show up in that room.
Let's try to spam it so she shows up.
That scared you.
My beloved.
Alright.
Okay, wait, do I have to go get the notes again?
I just want to make sure.
Okay, I do, great.
I wish I would just save that.
Spindly lady, where you at?
Come on, show me that cat.
There's one more big room if I go up.
What are you talking about?
I'm in the big room.
Yeah, I'm down here.
Now I'm up here.
Wait, but there must be one to the side.
But how? How do I get to the one to the top side?
Show me that fire.
It's like grimace shake.
The shakes are pretty good, I won't lie to you.
What if, is it through here?
Do I have to break one of the glass?
Because it's up here to the right.
Oh, it's the room that's watched the candles.
Oh, wait, you're right, you're right, you're right.
You're right.
It's over here.
I have to go in that room again anyways.
Just check in, just check in, you know.
I always want to check.
Good night.
Stop.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no one.
Wait.
If we're in the same room.
We're in the same room, where are you?
Throw yourself.
Guys, what's happening?
What do I do?
How do I get to the damn basement?
I need to kill that lady.
It's giving me a hint.
Oh, she's up here with me.
I'm on, I'm at a loss.
I don't know what to do.
Cringe.
You know what, I've taken 30% of this crisp dollar bill.
You streamlapsed today.
Thank you, I didn't see that.
I guess I'll just grab everything again.
What can I like, is there a way to save?
Okay, I guess not.
If I go back between the rooms too fast, it'll kill me.
I wish I could get that first note again.
What is this thing randomly on the floor?
I don't know what that is.
None of these pictures or anything.
So do I have to go between to the rooms really fast for her to come get me?
Do I have to have her come get me?
If I already collected the notes, do I have to collect them again?
I just need to meet her along her path.
Well, if I go down here...
Okay, well, she's in the next room.
Oh, and the screen shakes I can kill her, because we're in the same room right now.
Alright.
Press escape and check notes.
Okay, yeah, so it doesn't save the freaking notes that I've already collected.
That's annoying.
I don't need the notes.
I don't, but it said that it said something about notes.
Isn't this like Sunderman?
Do I need to collect the notes?
Alright, I don't focus on that then.
Why are you in the hallway? Come over here.
Oh my God, lady.
It's just the lore? Okay.
Where are you?
Come here.
I don't want to go too fast.
Come on, lady.
Oh my God, why are you still in the hallway?
Okay, she's coming back around, so I should be able to meet her down here.
I think?
What are you doing? Get out of there.
Get out of the hallway.
I kind of don't want to fight you in the hallway. It's like the worst place for us to fight.
I don't like that that keeps popping open.
Lady, I swear to God, if you don't let me kill you.
Finally.
I'm ready.
Oh.
It's hard to hit it.
Please.
God, please.
Got her a little bit. Got the tail end.
Oh, please.
Fuck.
Damn it.
The endurance fight.
Getting a sauce on my spindly lady.
You know what the creepiest thing I remember being freaked out about was the bent neck lady from Haunting a Hill House.
That scared the crap out of me.
And the old man with the bowler hat.
Actually, I prefer to fight her in the other room besides this one's kind of a hard room to fight in.
Like over here.
And I come back down maybe.
I love Haunting a Hill House. I watched it like three times the entire series.
Yeah.
Watch the candles. Oh, no. Watch them.
I think my crosses is better than all these crosses.
Why is she all the way up there?
Ma'am.
Oh, my God.
I know she's like following my path probably, but like, it's annoying.
Oh, here we go. Fine, I'll just fight her again in here.
Any moment now.
Ma'am.
Yeah, I love Flanagan stuff. My Flanagan is awesome.
Are you serious?
Come on then.
You're fucking nonce. Let me fucking... Jesus Christ.
Let me put you out of your fucking misery then.
Oh, my Lord.
Just a little shy. Just a little.
Alright. Okay, I don't know why I couldn't...
I'm gonna...
Alright.
That was a good one.
Yeah.
Nope. Oh, I still got it.
Die. Dammit.
Frick. She gets like too fast sometimes.
It's good when she's like far away.
Oh, she was too close for me to step out the way.
Rip.
Alright, let's go try to tease her again.
I really want a Pop-Tart. I know why.
The smell of a Pop-Tart just wafted into my head for some reason.
The thing is, she doesn't show up right now. I don't understand why it glitches like that.
Frickin' come out! I swear to God, lady.
Oh, my God.
You were taking too long to show up so I had to spam it.
Like a true FPS player.
She's taken too long to show up.
Morty's Morty.
Come on, I'll fight you up here.
What, you moved down?
Oh, my God, lady.
Where are you going?
Where did you come from? Where did you go? Where did you come from? Cotton-eyed Joe.
Oh, great. Now I'm going to fight you in this really tiny ass room.
Oh, was I supposed to put up my cross when that happens?
Boomi, did you just get scared by my foot?
Boomi, what are you doing?
Frick.
Why aren't you showing up yet?
Is this the room you just don't want to fight in?
Oh, okay.
Geez. Oh, I didn't turn around the way.
What?
Okay.
No.
Not the narrow hallway fight.
Yeah, I can't really move around.
Morty, that's what I'm saying.
Oh, we're back. She's here, though.
Oh, spindly lady. Let me spindle your lady.
Where are you hiding, miss spindly lady?
Oh, spindly lady, show us your wisdom.
I'm going to start breakdancing with my magnum dong.
Please.
Show yourself. You know what? I'm picking a different room to fight in, then, because you're taking too long.
All right, we're in the same room.
Show yourself.
I'm going to get a fucking seizure.
I'm literally just unfocusing my eyes right now on accident.
She hates me.
I don't understand why she doesn't. Is that like a game glitch or am I just stupid?
Should I be doing something else besides standing in the room that she's in?
Or do we have to fight in the church?
Well, no, that's not true, because I just fought over there.
All right, well, it's not a game glitch.
Okay, what else should I be doing?
If I show a little leg.
I'm showing a little leg.
You like that?
Leg, leg.
I'm her, her, her, her, her, her, her.
Take a pic, it's me, me, me, me, me.
Sorry, I've been like, that's been my song I've been listening to on repeat lately is her by Megan Thee Stallion.
All right, well, she's just following me now.
Bring on Foul Beast.
I'm going to sit in this table then.
Who are we behaving for the most part?
Between my legs, I'm showing her what's, I'm showing her my third leg and nothing's going on.
She's not.
Oh my God, this spindly whore.
Come out.
She's trolling me hardcore.
Oh my gosh, she really jumped to the next room.
Stop opening that.
Come here.
Oh my God.
Okay, let's do this, let's do this.
Come on, come on, I'm standing in the center of the room.
I'm getting juked by a ghost, and then a ghost.
What the hell?
No, Bumi.
Bumi, no.
Bumi, I can't see.
Bumi, you can't lay on Fia.
Bumi, please.
I can't tell what's happening.
Bumi!
I can't even tell where to point.
Bumi, move your freaking, oh wait, I can't do that.
I'm going to hold you like a baby for your crimes.
This is what you deserve, you deserve to be held like a baby.
Yeah, oh you're so cute.
Oh, he's a boy.
Little baby.
Yeah, he's a baby boy.
Oh, give me some toes, ooh.
I need to clip your toenails.
The pinks on your back toes are pretty long,
I should be mindful of that.
Maybe I'll file them instead.
You got like rabbit feet, bro.
Your little pretty blue eyes, why are your eyes so blue?
Usually they're lighter.
I'll give you a kiss with your little airplane ears.
Oh, you look like a little baby.
You're just a little baby.
Oh no, you can't even, baby.
All right, you can leave.
I'm so full from that stuff.
All right, let's lock in, bros.
Yeah, I like this room best.
She's getting faster.
She's calling me Jake.
All right, we did it.
Wait, I want to see what this room looks like.
No, okay.
Nothing changed.
We locked in, boys.
We got stuck on a pew, but we locked in.
Yeah, let's go into the scary basement.
Darkness surrounds thee.
She's calling full well as she waits for me ahead.
Checking my old watch has revealed something quite astonishing.
Time doesn't change down here as we know it on the surface.
But now, the hands don't move past.
Who?
God's work we done.
I have bent to earth on the faintest light shine.
Checking for things unspeakable.
God help me, Father Clark, foolish old man,
going mad in this dark prison.
He was bleeding from the screams.
Oh, the demon.
This is one of the confusing parts of the game.
I didn't want to give you any wrong info.
Oh, okay.
Ah, dance dance revolution.
Good thing I'm good at this.
I don't know what started Sandstorm, but yeah.
What?
Hold on. Let me look at this.
Ladder and hole that HXF.
Ladder and hole.
Oh.
H, where's the H? There's no H.
H.
What the hell am I doing?
What the heck is that?
Clock holds all the power.
Is that the watch then?
Because clearly this at the bottom here means something.
Quick, take a mental picture.
I got a fart.
Done.
What the hell?
You're doing it right if a symbol doesn't go away?
I didn't even step on anything.
What the frick?
Well, I'm going to die.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
He says the blind man peeing in the wind.
It's all coming back to me now.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
Okay, no ladies.
Yeah.
You know what's cooler than being cool?
Ice cold.
Fuck.
Oh, so close.
Okay, so it's like a path.
Nope, that's not the right one though.
That's how my skull just like, oh, I know that's my cross.
So it's these.
Okay, so you go across.
Here.
Okay, not that one.
So go across.
Here.
Nope.
What the hell?
No.
Okay.
Da, da, da, da, da, da.
What?
I am a little confused.
Yeah.
It is.
It does have to do with the wheel.
Hello.
I don't know why I couldn't go down.
All right.
Frick.
Okay, don't go that way.
Yeah, the wheel is the pattern.
I just can't remember what the pattern is.
I'm not going to take a fricking picture with my phone or maybe I should because I can't
memorize that because it starts at two because it's the clock.
And you go around, you go bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup.
That one.
And then that one.
Okay.
But I don't see that symbol.
But that symbol isn't over here.
Do I just cross all the way to this one?
No.
That doesn't make any sense.
I'm missing a symbol.
Just walk onto the hand.
Oh.
Cool.
Nice.
Nifty.
Cool.
These guys are all having a great time.
I don't really know.
They kind of look like they're just all just hanging out.
They got like a mosh, like moshin'.
Why did I come out of an outhouse?
That's kind of weird.
The heck am I?
How do I help the little boy in the field and why did that tree run away from me?
Music's so good.
Doomed to forever wander.
Oh.
Look at all these deer.
I look so funny walking.
Sometimes it looks like the black on either side of the white, which is supposed to be
his neck and it's like the face.
Doesn't that look like a face a little bit?
A mouth opening going up.
Okay.
Hello.
How do I get out of here?
Oh my God.
Can I go back and take a poop?
It was just flavor.
Okay.
How do I leave the woods?
Do that poop.
Imagine hiding your cult in an outhouse.
That's pretty sick.
Right.
I'm stuck in pixel slender man.
I like how I'm going left.
I need to sit down right.
Follow the path the trees are taking me.
Okay.
I can't tell what you mean.
All right.
Because it's a clearing here.
Let's go.
We'll go this way.
Oh.
These guys are having a great time.
Okay.
What.
Huh?
Investigators are asking residents to report any suspicious activities to the police.
Authorities are urging the people of Stirling to not mourn the loss of Atwood, Nogales and
Inglis because after all, they were degenerate, devil worshipping thugs who were hooked on
crack.
Okay.
That's like, you would like them to think.
Where did you join?
There were just three.
We're actually in the community of favor when you felt I'm getting high in that too.
We stalked them to the graves and killed them all one by one and ignored their cries
for help and pleas for mercy.
We're holes in drug addict bodies that you chopped off their heads because everybody
knows our heads are the only way to kill a snake.
Look at us and what?
You gotta kill a snake, John.
Can it kill or cannot be killed?
I wish I'd already saw both of them.
Okay, let's both put it down again.
Now I'm gonna spot the kill, baby.
I wish I wanted to try my works for the end of the works.
The end turns around again.
That's all.
If it now sheds out, then I don't want it.
My hand does not die for it.
You see your fault.
I will have my soul for I am gone.
Ring around the Rosy.
Wha...what.
I'm a demon sick anyways time to do demon shit
kill him oh damn it you can't kill him what the hell
that's crazy candy tunnel can I just kill these unsuspecting people
hey you guys stuck can I help you it looks like the rocks point has an arrow down
I could have sorry I hold on I have to climb this hill can only a demon climb
this let me up damn it too weak it's only a demon hill damn it I wanted to kill them
can I go back to my last save if I quit will it go back
oh sweet demon time demon time it's demon time demon time boys
can I kill her damn it he got away haha nice try bitch
oh I want to kill the both of them because I didn't know how to press space to kill
him hold on Rena's on my lap hi Rena Rena I almost got Isekai all right I'll kill him
yeah yeah I get these little bitches they get them gonna get them sick them sick them
come here what are you kidding me I will kill the both of them sorry can I only kill one
of them it like wasn't letting me kill her sorry I just wanted to get the secret I can
kill both I think I thought so can I just go up no I like my little like piano playing
noises I'm gonna get ya demon she be he's gonna get ya haha yeah part of the bad ending
oh that sucks oh a free car huh crazy wait what's the bad ending okay now what the bad
endings are fun is the bad ending worth it or should I should I just cuz I'm not gonna
like replay and do multiple endings I already missed the other steps no I want to turn into
the demon come on it's too late for the bad ending all right whatever I killed them for
fun then am I in a sewer I need to use my eye blood and sacrifice the child for I couldn't
find the child I want it I would have sacrificed the child I'll be turned into a demon not
I've been sick hello don't particularly like that music someone was shooting up over here
alright I'm not doing the whole reading thing I'm just gonna read it do you want to reset
ah that's fine used to make a pentagram oh okay so I was right I did have to cuz when I walked out
with the eye blood I had a feeling I had to make a pentagram cuz I'm just like oh yeah cuz I talked
with a star and I'm like so that's why I thought when I opened the gate I just form a pentagram
but then it did it automatically I wish I could like go back to like save individually cuz then
I would go back and do that but whatever why do they call it candy tunnel excuse me great
there's a murderer down here named Joe you miss part of the straight you know what that's
alright that's alright and pal you're fine you're good satin lives yeah they do it's a great thing
what's that red thing in there the blood it's a great stop running where are you going I don't
like the music the music is terrifying read alright what's it say when see when you see it
don't move okay when I see it don't move okay I'm like what if I just
you know pull out my well my thing little cheekily trolled quit peek it at me from behind the greats
you weirdo like how it like uses its little oh it has hands for all that's so cool
that's cool I like it when you see a dance dance revolution no just goes off into the
wall I suppose clab pillow I don't that says oh oh making my way down the block with my
Glock your ass finna get shot blah blah blah blah blah blah blah that's a silence up blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
There's a lot of exploring I need to do blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
No, I don't like it. I don't like that. It's a flashlight
What the fuck are you?
Well, I what?
What?
It's a child. Ah, it's the twins
Ah
Twins, help
Did I stun lock on what's happening here?
Where is he? Oh
How where the fuck is he? Ah
What the fuck is that kid doing?
Why are you running around purple child? I don't even know what that did
Bye bye have a good one. Hello purple child. Thank you for your help
It's the twins it's the twins
Wait
The lady said that she lost the baby was it the twins
Because you don't see them in the picture
Sorry, I thought there was a door down here. I guess one in the house
What the fuck is this guy doing
Wait, did me and this red person make those purple babies? I'm kidding
All right, let's walk on the fun little
He is here I am here
Ah
Yes enter hidden sanctum, where the fuck am I?
Baphomet
What are you doing here Baphomet
This music is freaky. Hey
hate
The light
They hate the light what
Purple children
That's just a door what the
Get me out of here bro. Get me out of here
Get me out of here
What the fuck are you?
Oh my god, why are the purple children writing in blood? Oh, what do I should I do this?
Why is the purple child running by
Does that do anything I'm holding up my cross
It's going on I don't freaking know purple children that's what
Oh
What the fuck
Come here
Go go away, can I make you go into a different room?
Hey, what do you want?
Fuck you fuck flipping them off
And just have to look at them go into the next room. How about that?
Where are they oh they're coming back they're just like we're still here go back go back over there
Get away motherfuckers
Oh
Another nerves, okay
Where where where where where where what are you guys doing?
Stop what the noise key
Oh
Finally there a baby being sacrificed what's going on here
All right now I still got to do shit
I'm assuming this pentagram is blocking the way for a reason can somebody turn on the lights, please
Oh
Sorry motherfucker
Yay yippee. Oh, thank God. I was tired of the flashlight
About the babies
Pentagram of blood baby sacrifice killed two on the overpass. Oh
Oh
Once you find a but what and aren't I right though is didn't I guess it right that the babies are the twins?
That the mom mentions in the beginning and that you don't see in the picture at the family photo because she lost them
And she thinks they're probably like alive still
Excuse me
Get fucked
What the hell are you
Where did you come from
Who are you
You just popped out of nowhere with a creepy-ass voice and then you're like let's fight them together
It's father Garcia father Garcia. What are you doing here?
That's true because you're the gray dude from earlier the team up
Honestly if this was made into a horror movie it would be incredible
And you just had a really like moody lighting all the time that matches the rooms. Oh, that would be so great
All right, let's go you got this oh
Oh, but I thought that was you I guess it wasn't hey
It's funny I literally commissioned artwork spoiler alert of me doing the Bafa met symbol of the as above so below
Because it's fucking sick hey told you guys I was pagan. What's up lady?
I
What
That movie is overrated look that was working on the last chapter. I
Think that's stupid-ass priest movie with what's his face from gladiator
Oh, I she moved
Alright I'm backing up then what the fuck I can't point diagonally. I'm limited in this game
Hey, can I skip this I really don't care about your stupid face
Where are you going
That's like not the place for you to stand because you're right near the door
Oh
Fuck the kill father Garcia, and then they killed me
I
That's hard all right, hey queen
With your little spindly fingies
Why are you going all the way over there you weren't standing there before
Okay, I'm gonna literally stand like right on you so that I can protect the both of us at the same time
I
That's a strat stand on father Garcia
Oh
Why are you standing all the way over here? This is like the worst spot to stand bro Jesus. Why are you right by the door?
No fuck damn it. I was doing so well
He didn't have the right signal for you so he moved I was close. Oh, yeah, let's try it again
I'm like, wait, why isn't he moving over here yet?
Oh
Okay, go on
Geez you fucking red bastards
I
Made it kill us both. Uh, that was weird. I was I thought I was pointing at it, but I guess I wasn't
All right, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. Hold on
Let me slap my clock my clock in your face if you know what I'm saying
You picking up what I'm putting down drop stick on table
Um
Sorry father you didn't have to hear that
No, I didn't turn far and I'm being sloppy. I'm sorry
I'm being sloppy I'm being sloppy. This isn't that hard. I'm just tired now. Oh
This is actually a good spot. Thank you
Yeah
Hold on I
Feel like you're not really doing anything father Garcia. I'm not gonna lie to you
Cuz like I'm the only one that's making her flash red
Oh
You're not flashing red. Okay, there we go. That was weird
No, no, no stay away from father Garcia
They're so fast
He's banishing her I don't know man, I'm the one that's making her flash red
You can only hear the Burger King foot lettuce
Stand right there. Thank you. The last thing you want in your Burger King
I go
Like I wish I could just rotate without moving that would make my life a lot easier
No, no, I gotta get to father fuck off
We're busy we're doing stuff that was fast
Yeah, if y'all could spawn on that side, that'd be great
Why are you getting so close to her or him I don't really know he's just wearing a shawl
Yeah, keep keep spawning behind her that's great actually
What what the frick
Oh
My god terrified
There's an 8-bit hag coming for me and running around. Can you please die?
Oh, are you shitting me right now?
Are you shitting me right now?
Phase two
Okay, that's fine
Whoa
Sicker father
I
Fuck is happening
Sorry your cross and they don't work though when you turned around sorry sorry
Did not work did not work when you turned it frick
Did not work when you turned around just does not happen
I
Fuck off
Stay away from father Garcia
What the fuck are you doing ah
You're dancing
Oh
Kill me I'm keeping him alive
Fuck go on without me father Garcia you got this
Me when I don't get Oreos
Yeah, why don't you why don't you come over here? Oh, what?
What the fuck I pointed at the one at the top or maybe I didn't cuz again
You'd think that him her flying over him would do something but apparently not all right
I
Kind of like how he just stands there. He's just like ah shit John John god damn it John
All right do what you must
No, don't go for father Garcia. No, I will not allow it
Oh
Fuck
Get her sicker sicker father Garcia
Die die I'm too close to you
I
Fuck
Why is my my color changed
All right flying like the wicked witch of the West over there
Hello
How's I
Okay, well now I know that father Garcia can't get hurt during that
Yeah
Fuck bro
It just doesn't have any rhyme or reason all fear
Sorry for yelling
Yeah, yeah
Yeah popi popi popi people die
I
Fuck me what
Bro
I I'm because I'm like I'll die if I say I'm a father Garcia is he won't but I will I'm not as go to this father Garcia
You know
I
I'm gonna kill my shelf in faith
Basically as dual her yeah
Fuck
I'm getting too tired for this. I'm like really sleepy all of a sudden
That food put me to food coma
Queen come back
Come back Queen. Oh perfect. Thank you Queen. Why do I have to do her?
Me hoy me no I
What
Is he supposed to die
No kill me that doesn't make any sense
No, all right kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me
I know I could still beat the boss of the father Garcia. I just want him to stay alive
I
They're Mary Poppins ass
Where the fuck are you going?
Are you serious bro father Garcia get out of the fucking way
Oh
My god, please I'm getting so tired. I might not be able to beat this on stream because I'm so sleepy
Father Garcia
Stay strapped already bro like come on. I can't be like fucking protecting you all the time. Oh
She almost went for him
If I hold the button it doesn't work if I hold it after that little phase it doesn't matter if I have the cross-up
Yep
Yeah, fuck you got this father Garcia. It's fine. You got it
You got it man
What the hell
Fuck
I'm Lily just gonna mirror his fucking movements
I can't hold the button. I can't hold it
Cuz then she just auto kills me cuz it doesn't matter. Oh my god, I'm starting to get mad
Don't you fucking do it this is not the best spot for you father
Yeah, come towards the middle, bro. No stay away from him
What was that
Her Mary Poppins ass
My home annoying
Oh
We got scared cuz I hit my hands on my desk
I
Thought he threw something no, that's boomy. I think he like flew into the brown bag
You
Right it is proper rabbit behavior to thump when I'm mad just like that
Cuz like I want to beat her but it's hard because I'm tired now I
Was facing the wrong way, I
Warted
This is the end of the chapter right fuck
If I when I beat the
I
Call you gee my name is Jeff. Yes. Okay. Okay, then I will be this
Okay, if I yeah, I got him out of this circle
No, she went right for Godfather Garcia
The second phase is like stupid long for no reason
I
Just don't understand how that killed me
Fuck off just Mary popping it up in here
Oh
Father Garcia do something oh he would oh interesting
What the hell I I swear I pointed to the side
I just want to finish this I just want to finish please please. Let me finish please. Let me finish. Oh my god, please
Yeah, Father Garcia come over here, please
Oh
This is starting to make me rage, man, I just want to stop flying around you fuck
I just I just I just
I
Is the boss of female I know I don't think it is I didn't just calling it a her cuz
It's just funny to think of it as like this angry hag. That's trying to kill me
Angry hag cult leader. This is angry woman. What the fuck boomie
Oh, oh, it's time for boomy snuggles. Oh boomy sniffing the mic time
But the boomy time
This one's for the one with the boom and system top down to the training the boom
Oh
Are you here to make me feel better angry hag we love those here. Yeah, she does like how I cook a bus
Boomy is here. He'd be sniffing the tomagotchi. He's checking on Fia
Yeah, just huffed at him like a telling him, please don't come over here
And lay on me here. Why don't you why don't you just be held by me boomy?
Raina sat on Fia's head
When I was napping well, I was about to start napping and I'm falling asleep and then Raina crawls on me
but like my body doesn't register it and
And then I hear Fia squeak and Raina's just completely sat on her head
So I had to move her and then Raina was no then Fia was playing with Raina's tail. It was cute
How did you kill me usually after a little bit of time it goes away
Boomy you can't be on my desk right now handsome boy. Oh
You're stop boomy, please. You're knocking over stuff boomy
I'm too tired for this bro. Get off my desk
Lady
Boomy get off my desk. Oh my god, boomy stop
Oh
Don't go for Father Garcia
Don't tell me I got to do this shit like three times cuz I'll be pissed
I don't get it
Literally with the time usually the time I put on her
Holding up the cross that kills her. I don't understand that I
Don't I don't get it. I just don't it's not consistent
Because sometimes I barely have to do it sometimes I have to do it forever sometimes I don't have to do it at all
I
Yes, this is harder than elder drink bro
I'm honestly about to turn off the sound because it's starting to irritate me you know what I'm doing that
I'm tired of hearing it
You know what you guys aren't gonna hear it either we're just gonna hear my my lovely background music
Cuz I'm tired of hearing this screaming it's kind of just like grating on my ears at this point
I
Where are you going? Okay
It's like funnier with the sound off
Because this looks silly I would definitely say a big part of the
The game is the sound
Because this this looks funny. No, I
Really got a backup when she does the fucking slow walk. Yeah
No
I
Bro I'm getting so frustrated right now. Oh
Cuz I'm tired, but I want to beat the game
What are you doing? Why are you going so fast?
Move the music off leans forward fuck your mother
Father Garcia come over here you fuck like I don't
She's gonna fucking go for you. Yeah, like oh my god, you're so fucking annoying. I
Know it's possible to save him. That's why I'm doing it with that save. Oh
Fuck back up when she slow walks. Yeah
You're right
Are you doing lady come back here
Oh my god, I literally can't leave father Garcia for a fucking second
Thank you for the don't know Chad by the way, thank you for the soup, but I appreciate it
Oh
Fuck
It's also like dependent on where Garcia is cuz like sometimes I just can't be close to him
That
Should have killed her that would have
His legs are giving out
Bitch
I
Not letting you die. I am determined now to win this with you being alive like I can't play it otherwise
I'm too sorry for this. I'm done. I'm too sleepy. I'm going to bed
I went to bed at 2 a.m. Last night. It's not four hours today. I'm tired. I'm done. I
Can't I can't do it. I'm sorry. I'll finish it next chapter
It'll be the first thing we start with but I'm just too tired and I'm getting angry
And because I'm getting angry I am I'm not able to play it properly
I'm so sleepy
Oh
Find somebody to raid. I'm gonna knock out. It's only 10 30. I'm so tired though. I
Know I'm gonna come back. I'm always the type of person. I'll come back to a game
Or like a boss fight. I'll just beat it the first try and I'm like, why did I get this the first time?
Let's see who we can read
You got a lot of people playing stuff
A lot of people on let's read someone new I'm trying to read outside of
My usuals, you know what?
Wait
Hmm, I'm curious. I'm not I want to see if this person just started streaming or not
I
Started streaming eight hours ago
Goddamn, I thought I was an endurance streamer
Goddamn
Should read Shiori
Look at this person. Okay, this person just started
Oh
The whole chat is catching up right now
What's happening? Is this what it feels like to be like a hollow when the chat moves that fast?
No, yeah, I know I know is there a streaming it but like I'm trying I'm trying to branch out
Let's see
Yeah, I'm gonna read them
Because they just started and they're cute. I love their model design they have one of my favorite model designs
All right, we're gonna read
The sweet and adorable trash pan
Rocky
Kazuki and you can just say
Bunny
Bunny bunny Boba Boba bunny raid
How about that? All right. Good night everybody
Morty it
Stay stinky everyone stay stinky. Why is my
My skin is like weird red
What's happening here
All right, bye viewers are reacting to Rocky's recent action and comments
They're joking about her edging them and use
I thought pixelate girls were say so what's happening here?
All right, bye guys go see how to rock you for me later